[Music]
welcome to Hannity and tonight in our
great country the United States of
America we have a country and Retreat
your President Joe Biden has ceded
control of our Southern border to
Violent Mexican cartels they are now
actually charging admission into the
United States uh complete with
wristbands like where what some kind of
amusement park that they own that they
operate then they flood the zone that
opens up other wide portions of our
border for human trafficking opioid
trafficking fentanyl trafficking we've
got those details ahead tonight plus it
is now official our national debt has
topped a whopping 33 trillion dollars
just today just in time for yet another
budget battle we have a deadline in 11
days let us be clear here this is not an
imaginary number this is debt that has
real consequences massive unfettered
government deficits that leads to tax
hikes that leads to inflation spikes
that leaves future generations with an
unthinkable burden your children your
grandchildren add to this disaster
America now under Joe Biden is
abandoning energy Independence the
results of which are as we all know
already catastrophic to you we the
American people everything now costs a
lot more not just filling up your tank
and heating and cooling your home but
every single item you buy at every store
you go to it all costs more and we have
now more than 61 percent of our fellow
Americans I've been there it's awful
living paycheck to paycheck many of
those 61 percent they can no longer even
afford basic necessities that were they
were able to afford less than three
short years ago now this as Washington
now continues their Reckless spending
some now want to even spend more and a
few they're fighting to reduce the
budget and coming up two House
Republicans Florida Congressman Matt
Gates and Texas Congressman chip Roy
they will debate how to best reduce the
deficit start paying back the debt as
the shutdown now looks inevitable in
what maybe 11 days and per usual Joe
Biden has fellow Democrats they want no
limits on spending they don't seem to
care how much inflation it causes
remember Biden's Domo catchphrase vowing
to quote build our economy from the
bottom up and from the middle out okay
apparently that was just another lie
thanks to inflation of the U.S poverty
rate is going up for the first time
since 2010. great job Joe but instead of
unleashing the power of free markets and
capitalism no Biden is bowing to The
Climate Gods all while paying Hefty dues
to climate the climate alarmist
religious cult are real problems you
know like poverty or borders inflation
law order safety security they all go
unchecked an imaginary problem the
so-called climate crisis is taking
Center Stage take a look
for one day
for one day my Administration the United
States has treated this crisis
as an existential threat from the moment
we took office
not only for us
but for all of humanity
now of course imaginary crisis require
imaginary Solutions so now your
President Joe Biden is spending billions
of dollars on windmills solar plants but
by the way states are now begging for
more money because they can't build them
at the money they thought they'd build
them at all while I'm posing costly
regulation on cars your lawn mowers your
stoves your ovens uh even your HVAC
units declaring war on the gas and oil
industry relying on countries that
frankly hate our guts for the lifeblood
of the world's economy not just ours oil
energy gas we have unilaterally now
disarmed our economy and our leadership
role in the world none of this will put
a dent in the perceived quote climate
crisis but here's where it gets truly
bizarre during his speech at the U.N
earlier today Bowden he vowed to partner
with China to save the Earth from carbon
take a look
stand ready to work together with China
on issues where progress hinges on our
common efforts
nowhere is that more critical than
accelerating the climate crisis than the
accelerating climate crisis oh then
maybe we should call them a developing
Nation as per the Paris climate Accords
China they took no responsibility for
the millions that died of covid they
blamed us for their spy balloon that
they flew over sensitive military
nuclear sites they did that for over a
week Joe didn't lift a finger they're
pretending that the uyghur genocide
isn't really happening it's happening
don't expect China to take
responsibility for being the world's
number one polluter if you ever seen the
pretty disgusting Skies over Beijing you
would kind of know the climate change is
pretty low on their list of priorities
and concerns somewhere below
mass-producing cheap plastic products
for profit and invading or threatening
to invade our Ally Taiwan now so by the
way so do the woke climate alarmists in
charge of the Biden White House do they
realize any of this at this time or are
we just witnessing a dumb mumbling
bumbling expensive Global exercise and
just virtue signaling now today even
zelinski was lecturing the world on the
so-called climate crisis at the U.N okay
Ukraine is right now facing a real
existential crisis but it doesn't have a
thing to do with the weather and of
course we all want clean air and water
under Donald Trump here are the facts
the U.S reduced carbon emissions by more
than any other country on Earth but not
with regulations and windmills instead
cleaned natural burning gas and new
technologies they're credited with the
reduction in pollution in our country we
led the way but the climate cult they
don't seem to care they need a doomsday
scenario to achieve their radical goals
for them this isn't ultimately about a
cleaner Planet their end goal is more
government control over your life a
bigger share of your paycheck a greater
say in your decisions more ownership
over your property in other words
socialism the climate crisis is just a
virtuous trojan horse for Global
collectivism republicans in Congress
they've got to reject this they've got
to stand strong I thought Republicans
you know thought that fiscal
responsibility was important question is
how well a serious budget battle is a
small but important step in the right
direction keep in mind government
shutdown is definitely not the end of
the world I've talked about that our
military they'll be on duty they'll
continue to get paid Social Security
checks in spite of the fear-mongering
they will go out to the people that
deserve them the VA our veterans
programs they'll all be funded and by
the way the people that get furloughed
they'll get hired back and probably get
back pay as they usually do trying to
use this as leverage to force the
Democrats hand and start you know we
need to get our Reckless spending under
control bring your case to the American
people before it's too late hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else